um
um
good morning everybody thank you for
being here today
i want to start off by mentioning that
we're trying to improve the situation
for all of you with the questions that
you're answering and also give
anyone who's watching the ability to
hear your question
so please work together to use the
microphones if you're not using the
microphone i'm going to ask you to get
to the microphone
to ask the question now starting off i'd
like to put some information out for
voters to help them
in trying to track their ballot there
are two systems in place one is being
sponsored by the secretary of state
ballot tracks so any voter who's trying
to track
information on the status of their
ballot through ballot track should
really put that question through the
secretary of state's office
my staff isn't capable of answering any
questions related to ballot tracks we do
not
use it the secretary of state who does
in my system on the website
clarkcountymd.gov forward slash vote
we have registered voter services and in
registered voter services our voters can
check to see the status of their ballot
as far as it being received by my office
all voters should be aware that
vote history will not be posted until
after the canvas
so if you're looking on the secretary of
state site to see if your vote was
posted and voted
you will not see that information that
information is not posted until after
the election
now i'm going to go through a series of
information here and then we're going to
give you an opportunity to ask
questions i have a change from yesterday
the expected turnout that i reported
yesterday was incorrect
the 51 000 votes that i reported would
be
available today is actually a little
over thirty thousand
and here's the reason why when we
process ballots on the counting board
our tracking mechanism changed from
precinct based ballots
to page numbers for the first time in
clark county the ballot is so large that
our ballot is actually two pages long
and so they have to track that when we
scan
ballots so that we can verify that the
count on those pages is correct
my staffer inadvertently and mistakenly
reported to me
that there were 51 000 precinct ballots
to count yesterday
and in actuality it was 51 000 pages
so that explains why when you saw the
updates today
you only saw 30 000 instead of the 51.
however the universe of ballots that i
communicated yesterday is still accurate
the only thing you need to do is take it
down approximately twenty thousand five
hundred from the fifty one to the thirty
thousand but the sixty three thousand
ballots that i reported yesterday
are in the state in the system in
various stages so those will still
expected to be report
reported beginning today
we will begin to re report our results
two times a day so you've already seen
the update for this morning
in the afternoon we will be putting up a
fresh report
on the mail ballots that have been read
into the system sometime before four
o'clock
we're required to report to the
secretary of state first
once they've met uh indicated to us that
they've received it and it's verified
we'll be able to post on our end
so rather than give you a specific time
i'll just tell you that
it'll be sometime before 4 p.m
now one more time i'd like to go through
the ballots that are separate from that
universe that i reported
we still have the provisional ballots
all of our laptops from election day
have been downloaded
so all of that information is available
to my staff today we will start in
earnest reviewing provisional ballots
there are 60 000 of those to go through
in in various categories now i want to
remind you that
we have to coordinate with the secretary
of state because again we are not a
top-down registration state we work from
the bottom up so all 17 counties have to
report to the secretary
they still have not given me the
instructions i know that they're on the
way
but at some point they'll let us know
when to send our report
up and that will be the tool that they
use to match against the other 16
counties in nevada to make sure that
nobody's
duplicated a vote in one county to the
next because we want to prevent that
once we do that we can begin to release
the provisional ballots
into count however that won't happen
until the secretary of state
verifies that report a reminder that
the id required voters their deadline is
today
at 5 pm for those who were required to
provide an id
that has to be sent to us by 5 pm today
we have a cure line available at
702-455-6552
where we have staff available to assist
those
individuals with getting that into us
the u.s mail update for this morning
we receive 241 ballots in today's mail
that will be added to that number that
i'm calling my my universe of ballots to
be counted
uh it's looking pretty clear that the
number of ballots is going to continue
to go down
however i wanted to ensure the general
public we have been working very close
with our regional supervisor
at the u's postal service and they're
doing an excellent job of reviewing
all of the post stations here in clark
county
in fact they have them sweeping
regularly more than once on a daily
basis
and if they identify anything that needs
to be delivered to the office they get
it to our office
within three to four hours it doesn't
even go to the process
of uh having set up for us to pick up
they're physically delivering those so
we appreciate their effort uh they're
making sure just as we are that we're
counting every ballot that's eligible to
be counted so our thanks to the u.s
postal service locally
the cure process is another group of
ballots that we need to process
they have until thursday the 12th of
november to cure that
my staff will not leave this facility
until we've counted all of those ballots
that have
been identified as security ab4 was very
clear in the legislative
legislative special session that we have
to have all ballots counted
by november 12th and with that i'll open
it up for questions remember you need to
be at the mic
good morning right there
right there whoever's dude yeah yeah
good afternoon
uh good morning uh mr registrar can you
tell us the number of ballots
that you expect in this afternoon dump
so you said
the 31 thousand was the total for this
morning it won't beat your 30 thousand
thirty one thousand i'm sorry thirty can
you so
let's just be clear here thirty thousand
four oh three was in thirty thousand
four oh three
this afternoon before four p.m how many
do you expect because we're starting to
dump two reports a day i can't
accurately give you that number
the only thing that i can tell you is
the numbers that i reported as my
universe
universal ballots that need to be
counted is still accurate so we know
we're gonna need
where we have staff running through
those we have to run those through those
two steps
and then at that point it moves to our
counting board our counting board then
works to verify those records
to make sure that our batches are
matching and that we're reconciling
correctly
and they go through the process of
separating the ballots and getting them
over here
for us to count so there's no speeding
up that process
as i indicated yesterday we're going to
continue to count and make sure that
we're being accurate
we're anticipating and hoping that with
the number of ballots that we see now we
should
hopefully be ready to have a final count
on the majority of mail ballots
by sunday at some time by sunday and
what's your message to all of the people
out there watching clark county
who say come on let's go hurry it up
i think i mentioned yesterday that our
priority here is to make sure that we're
accurate in what we're doing
so we're not interested in moving as
fast as we can we want to be accurate
we're very fortunate at this point that
we've had staff working for many days
and they're very efficient in what
they're doing
so we're confident that the work is
being done accurately
and that's what our our main goal is
can you talk about the circumstances
that require
an id what are those id required ballots
because there's quite a
a lot of them and how are those
different from the other ballots that
need to be cured
the easiest explanation for the cure is
that those voters who send back a mail
ballot that is not signed at all
or that has a signature that doesn't
match all of our history of signatures
in the system
they enter into the cure process that's
statutorily required and we have to mail
a notice to the voter and if the voter
has given us an email
or a phone number we also contact them
through an automated message
with that as well those are the cures
the id required can come from many
different areas
in the state of nevada now we've
implemented same-day registration
the online registrations that go through
the secretary of state's nova site
state law requires that those voters
show up to vote
our system indicates that they're
registered online they're required to
show an id
so they showed up to vote in person
either early voting or election day
and they didn't have their id so they're
required to provide that by today at 5
pm in order for
those votes to count we also have a
large number of mail ballots everybody's
well aware that we've sent a mail ballot
to all active registered voters in clark
county
so there's not as much familiarity from
the general public on what to do with
the mail ballot
we very clearly indicate on the mailing
envelope
those voters who need to send in an id
because in their registration
we were unable to match correctly with
our check with dmv or social security
and so they must provide an idea another
order for us to hold up the integrity of
the process
so in those two groups that's the
majority of the ids that are required
next question joe a new federal lawsuit
has
uh the from the trump campaign has
requested that
the use of the agility system be stopped
completely
and that instead all ballots be uh
verified by hand the signatures be
verified by hand
what would that do to the counting
process if your access to agilis
is uh lost
if they were successful i will mention
that that's already been heard in court
and that request was denied so
we're hoping that that stays consistent
however if we were unable to use the
agilis machine
we're working hard to get everything
through now so we won't have to worry
about that but that would slow down our
process tremendously
because we've geared our process to
count on the agility machine so we'd
have to go completely manual at that
point
and so yeah it would slow down our
process without a doubt next question
um so the nevada gop uh has confirmed
this morning that they have dropped
or have come into an agreement with the
county on the lawsuit that was issued
yesterday can you comment on that
your question was that the nevada gop
has
they've confirmed that the campaign has
dropped the federal lawsuit that was
issued out yesterday
well i may be incorrect but i think
they've reinstituted that so i'm
i don't know if you have the current
information from last week
hi uh mr gloria just to be completely
clear yesterday you said there were
63 262 outstanding ballots correct
okay we have those 30 000 uh that new
badge and then
so the outstanding balance would be
around 30
no sure no that's 33 000. you're confu
you're confusing the two numbers that i
reported so yesterday
what i stated that was that we expected
to see 51
000 ballots read yesterday correct
because
the page numbers were reported
mistakenly instead of the precinct count
that count went down from 51 to 30.
right so the 60
let me finish so the 63 000 are still
in process and need to be counted so
bottom line i mean outstanding balance
right now
out of that number of 63 000 still 63
000 24 hours later
that is correct
63 000
i wish you'd come to the mic so that i
could hear you well anybody who wants to
answer ask a question
please take the time to come up front
we're going to go right here
um mr gloria you mentioned uh receiving
i think 241
ballots to their postal service today
how many
do you know have you received since
election day
oh i'm sorry i'm not prepared for the
entire total
i i have today's yesterday in
yesterday's press conference i believe
that i mentioned that
oh no i do have it here so for election
day and wednesday the mail intake was
4208.
next question good morning in the
lawsuit that was filed today
in addition to acting for the agilis
machine to be stopped again they also
allege that there were 3
000 plus instances of ineligible ballots
which were cast
do you have any evidence of that that
has been given to you and do you have
any knowledge of those 3 000 ballots
that the nevada gop is alleging they
provided us with a list
we'll have to begin to look through that
however
um their lawsuit is based on something
that happens regularly
you don't have to live here in order to
be eligible to vote here
this is a military town we have nellis
air force base
we also have several students that
travel outside of the state
to go to school those folks are eligible
to vote
here in nevada we also have a
local representative congressman
senators they're up in washington
working but they live here they vote
here so
we'll have to look through those numbers
but it's not out of the ordinary at all
for somebody not to live here
but be eligible to vote here so we will
look at that and we'll review it
you need tonight sorry just to quickly
follow up on the number of military
ballots
um sort of related but separate you had
also said the other day that's part of
what you're going through in addition to
provisional ballots
how many outstanding military ballots
are there do you know
the military ballots have been read into
the system
hi sorry can i just clarify the math
yes total number of outstanding ballots
including the provisional
is what the provisional are beginning to
be looked at in earnest today because
all of the data is just
numbered i'll answer the question the
provisional account will be 60 000.
okay mail ballots that still need to be
run through the system and are expected
to run through for count
it's 63 262 approximately
okay and are we subtracting 30 000 from
that 63 or not no
so none of the 63 have been counted no
sir so where
where is that 30 000 number that you
mentioned this when you can you report
today check the website clark county
nv.gov forward slash vote
okay but so that why doesn't why isn't
that coming out of the 63
because i mentioned yesterday that we
had 51 000 ballots to count that was
incorrect
because i was given the number of pages
right 30
000 is in the system and reported this
morning
so 30 000 so there's still sixty three
thousand and the sixty thousand beyond
the thirty thousand
don't mumble so thirty thousand were
counted yesterday
that is correct there are still sixty
three thousand mail ballots
to be counted that is correct and sixty
thousand provision
those won't all be counted don't won't
meet the requirements for them to be
registered but they need to be reviewed
okay and what are the hours of the
counting
the hours of what's up what are the
hours that your people are working on
the count
i can have a member of my staff make
that available and how many people
roughly are involved in this process at
least 300
really okay thank you you're welcome
mr gloria at the risk of going back to
math
from 51 000 we reported 30 000
does that leave 21 000 no sir okay
and i i started out by explaining that
the numbers i reported yesterday were
incorrect and i gave an explanation as
to why
our staff at the accounting board
incorrectly mistakenly
provided me with the number of pages
that they sent over to be read however
that was not the number of precinct
ballots
every ballot in nevada that's sent to
the voters represents
two pages and so there were actually
only 30 000 ballots that were read so i
corrected that
and explained to you why that occurred
so
the 63 262
and no more than that no there could be
more
we still have cures we still have ids
that need to be
and we still have provisionals and then
those are all outside of the universe
that i've been reporting
and then the final are the 241
that you said you received by the minute
that's today sir you included
through the mail and that will continue
to be received through next tuesday are
they
included in sixty three two six no sir
those are outside of that
and thank you
joe i think the most all of the
confusion lays in
why hasn't that number gone down what
happened between
not with the misreporting of the number
but then why hasn't the number of
ballots that were counted
gone down
between you're referring to the 63 000
as we speak they're reading them into
the system some of those so it is going
down
it's just not in this morning's report
this morning's report only goes up to
the end of day yesterday
and so they're now processing those
we'll have some numbers to report just
before four o'clock on that 63
000 and we'll continue to do so until
we're finished with all of those ballots
joe right here so um and i'm staying on
the math
sorry i'm alright here staying on the
mats was it 63
000 and then the additional 60 000
provisional ballots does that mean is it
a
123 000 or am i confusing
60 000 provisional ballots need to be
reviewed
they won't all be eligible to be cast
but yes they
still need to be reviewed but i can't
tell you how many of those will be moved
forward to count
um the gop has uh asked the department
of justice to
investigate um some of the
and i'm just wondering if you received
the uh
the list of the voters names that um
they're looking into and what's your i
need you to be more specific with what
list you're referring to is it in the
lawsuit that they recently provided or
their list that i'm not
aware of regarding the they're asking
the department of justice to investigate
i don't know anything about that i can't
answer that question
a deal was struck a line more first um
to come in uh can you go into out that
deal
i can't hear you uh
observers have any
information regarding that deal it's
part of that lawsuit from last week
that was cleared i believe that we
agreed to provide some more observer
locations in our county boards
location okay but they've rescinded that
so i do
i'll have to talk to my civil d.a
okay i'm sorry i wasn't a good math
student
i'm trying to get like a final tally
what we're expecting so there's 63
000 provisional ballots that need to be
reviewed correct
correct in addition to that there's
another sixty thousand ballots that
aren't provisional
that need to be that are provisional but
there's those won't all be qualified to
vote they need to be reviewed
but ballpark for me what so are we
looking at 120 000 ballots need to be
reviewed and are audited and counted or
is it
63 000 and change that let's make sure
and clarify that there's two types of
tally types that you're referring to
provisional is electronic those are
voted on the in-person voting machines
the mail that i'm referring to is
separate that's a different tally type
so that's the 63 000. so there's some
electronic ballots that were voted
provisionally that all need to be
reviewed they're held in queue
so they won't actually be counted until
my staff correctly identifies whether
they were eligible to be counted
so that's separate but they're 60 000
plus the 63
000 that i've been referring to so
there's roughly so
just clarify for me we're looking at
roughly 123 000
ballots that still have to be reviewed
audited and or accounted
is that correct that's what i'm
reporting but you need to keep in mind
that we still have no id voters that can
show up we still have
cures that can still show up and we also
have u.s mail
okay so i'd love to make it easier for
you but it's a complicated process
i think we all appreciate what i'm
trying to do is give you the numbers on
the large
sure i think we all need a ballpark to
be able to accurately report we don't
want to say 60 000.
i think it's fair to say that the 63 000
mail and the 60 000 provisional
are the largest chunks left that we have
to interview and and
again not to misquote you i hope i
didn't misunderstand but you anticipate
having
those completed counted by sunday is
that exactly what i said
the mail so we're hoping to have the
mail done by sunday if all goes well and
that number again is what i'm sorry
sixty thousand sixty three thousand okay
okay so we're anticipating sixty three
more thousand ballots being completed
count it by
sunday and then there's the other sixty
thousand that's you have to be reviewed
which we'll go through next week
you've got it thank you next question
can i change away from math for a moment
how's your security we've been we've
been reading about
uh situation in philadelphia have there
been any credible threats to your
knowledge
to the voting uh count or your
facilities
in in around las vegas i i really can't
release any of the reports on anything
that would be credible we keep that
within our law enforcement group and
they are dealing with it
i can tell you that they're monitoring
social media for any threatening type of
messages
as you can see when you came today we we
have a a relatively large force of law
enforcement plus our
county uh security that's here in place
um so i i feel that the response has
been
excellent from the community from the
commissioners who called to make sure
that we had
um that support um
but i i it's just troubling for my
employees i have employees who are
nervous leaving the building
um and right rightfully so they worked
late into the night
so we strongly encourage all of them not
to leave by themselves
they can also request an escort from our
security people or law enforcement
so we're doing everything we can to
protect our employees and i
i think the response from local law
enforcement and the assistant we
received from our
county commission has helped to make
sure that that happens so
we're doing the best we can folks we
have two more questions
how yesterday that you plus these
numbers to
yesterday we have 40 44 000 id requiring
ballots and
2 100 ballots in the cube process is the
same number today
you know what i was looking for you can
you do that again i didn't see you i'm
sorry
she just said again yesterday we're
talking about
four thousand four hundred uh forty four
thousand
id requirements ballot and today and
yesterday we have two thousand
one hundred ballots in the cure process
is the same number today
i would have to run that report for you
i did not come prepared with those
numbers
but those were accurate yesterday
as i mentioned outside of that universe
of numbers the
mail and the provisional we still have
the id required
we still have the cures and we still
have the u.s mail that still has to come
through
so yes the answer to your question is
those people are still eligible if they
bring us an id
to have their ballot counted one more
question where is it
last question right here last question
right here
joe can you talk about the settlement
that came with the lawsuit going into
last week the reason behind it and just
anything moving forward
a brief i can just briefly say that the
republicans had communicated to our
legal team
that they were willing to drop their
suit if we would provide
some additional locations in an area
that we were providing it as a courtesy
again i remind all of you the only thing
that is statutorily required for
observers is we allow them to watch us
cap
count and tally votes which is happening
right behind us
everything else that we've provided is
provided as a courtesy we're not
we're not required by law to do so but
that that's what the settlement dealt
with but
they've rescinded it so i'll have to
talk to my civil d.a to see
where we're at with that thank you all
very much we'll see you tomorrow
at 10 a.m
today
i'll deal with you later sorry chris all
right guys um